One year and 13 days ago, I lost my husband Dave.
One day, my friend Adam Grant, a psychologist,...
...suggested that I think about how much worse things could be.
This was completely counterintuitive to me.
I would've thought that getting through something like death...
...was about finding every positive thought I could.
"Worse?" I said to him.
"Are you crazy? How could things be worse?"
He looked at me and said,...
"Dave could've had that same cardiac arrhythmia driving your children."
The minute he said it, I felt overwhelming gratitude that my children were alive...
...and that gratitude overtook some of the grief.
My hope for you is that you can find that gratitude,...
...not just on the easy days like today,...
...but on the hard days when you will need it.
You are not born with a fixed amount of resilience.
It's a muscle.
You can build it up and then draw on it when you need it.
And in that process, you figure out who you really are,...
...and you just might become the very best version of yourself.